-It feels like San Francisco,
but it don't feel
like San Francisco.
[ Cellphone ringing ]
-There's nobody
driving that car!
I'm freakin' out here!
Excuse me, lady.
Where are we?
Ma'am, ma'am?
Can you help us?
-Cardi B.
O-M-G, L-O-L.
-What?
-L-O-L?
-L-O-L.
[ Messaging apps beeping ]
-What the [bleep]
are you talking about?
Hello?
-What are those glowy rectangles
they're staring at?
Are they Pop Tarts?
-Goddammit, Freddy, you think
everything's a Pop Tart!
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Pete Davidson,
everybody.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
"The Freak Brothers."
-"The Freak Brothers," on Tubi.
-Yeah.
-This is --
So I want to talk about "SNL."
-Yeah.
-It's always shocking to me,
because you started
right after I left.
-Yes.
-And you started, like,
younger than most people start.
And now it kind of --
I remark on the fact
that you've been there
for quite a while now.
You're still --
You're kind of like
a pro over there.
-Yeah, I've been there
for eight years.
-That's amazing.
Congratulations, man.
-Thank you. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's been pretty wild.
-Do you still get
the butterflies on show night.
-Oh, boy, Seth, do I ever.
-Yeah?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes, yeah,
but it's always just, like,
you're surrounded by the
funniest people all the time.
You know?
-That always gave me
more butterflies, not less,
so, you know...
-Well, I definitely
never felt less funny.
I don't know
if you've ever felt that way.
-I definitely felt that way.
-But, like, when I'm there,
I'm just like,
"Oh, I'm garbage."
Yeah.
No, 'cause you watch, like, Kate
or, like, Chloe or Kenan
do like
a hundred million things.
And then, like, my line will be,
like, "Hey, everybody!"
[ Laughter ]
You know?
So it's just like...
[ Laughter ]
You know.
-I mean...
-I know my place.
-You crushed it.
-Oh, thank you.
-You crush it.
I want to ask this -- Saturday
musical guest, Taylor swift.
-Yes. We're very --
-Yeah.
[ Cheering ]
We have her on this show
Thursday.
And it's very rare
for this to happen for me,
but people have reached out
and said,
"I'd love to come Thursday,"
friends of mine.
Have you had that happen
with Taylor coming on Saturday?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-All of a sudden, all my cousins
are just like...
-Yeah.
-You realize there's just --
You think everybody
who hosts "SNL" is famous
until, like, somebody like
Taylor Swift comes through,
and then, your phone
doesn't stop ringing.
-Yeah, nobody is leaving me
alone about it.
I just tell everybody that,
like, I don't have --
they don't give me tickets.
-Yeah.
-Because I cause problems.
[ Laughter ]
And what's sad is that
nobody ever questions it.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean? Yeah.
I'm like, "Oh,
they took my tickets away."
[ Laughter ]
-It's funny that even the people
that know you would be like,
"Oh, yeah,
I wouldn't trust
whoever Pete would bring."
-Yeah! Why would you?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-For me -- I don't know if this
ever happens to you, because,
like I host this show every day.
And then,
someone like Taylor comes,
and then, people reach out,
and they're like,
"We'd love to come to the show,"
and I'm like,
"I'm here every night."
-Right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"As your oldest friend,
I'm here every night."
-"Yeah, you can come any time."
-And they're like,
"Oh, I'm only free on Thursday."
-On Thursday.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this is
a weird coincidence.
I guess it's not a coincidence,
but it wasn't --
we didn't plan on having two
fashion models on the same show.
-Oh, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Especially two
who have collaborated.
-Yeah, we -- we collaborated.
Yeah.
-So you actually
did a photo shoot for --
What was the name
of the product?
Moose...?
-Moose Knuckle.
-Yes, very cool coats.
-Very cool coats.
-And also, I think,
is that, like, a [bleep]
in tight pants?
Isn't that a moose knuckle?
-Is that a moose knuckle?
-I thought.
That's what my uncle told me.
-That's what
your uncle told you?
-Yeah. My uncle was like,
"Ah, moose knuckle!
I think your aunt
has one of those."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "What the [bleep]"
-Your aunt Has one?
-I guess my aunt --
I don't know
what's going on anymore.
[ Laughter ]
-They're worried.
They took your tickets away
'cause they're worried
you're gonna invite your uncle.
-Yeah. Now they're gonna --
[ Laughter ]
-All right, so here you are.
Here's a Moose Knuckle ad.
And by the way, they're so happy
with everything you've said
about their product so far.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, whatever they paid you,
they've gotten it back tenfold.
-For sure. They're so
comfortable coats, please.
[ Laughter ]
-But here's Emily.
And, you know, this is --
Obviously this is
a professional --
I mean, she's made that face.
-That's a professional model,
right?
-Yeah.
-And then, you go over here.
That's a professional model.
And then, zoom in
on this [bleep] idiot.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that moron
that's just...
[ Laughter ]
"I got a fishy!"
"Look at me and my fishy!"
-I like that you show up
and you were like,
"I think maybe Emily and I
are, like,
making cool faces and fishing."
-Yeah, and they were like,
"No, dude, you're in the hole."
I was like --
It was so funny 'cause my --
They called me,
and they were like, you know,
Moose Knuckle," who I love,
"said --"
Oh, so comfy coat.
They were like, "Dave --
Dave LaChappelle
wants to shoot it.
And I know Dave, so I was like,
"Wow.
He's getting a little
full of himself.
He's going by
"La" Chappelle now?
[ Laughter ]
And then --
I wrote that one
in the elevator.
Come on. That's a good --
That's a good joke.
-That's a good joke.
-That was just a good joke.
-He's so fancy.
He got all that Netflix money.
He got so fancy.
-"I'm Dave LaChappelle."
[ Laughter ]
I love Chappelle so much
because it's --
Do you remember, like,
when he was away for like --
15 years ago,
when he was doing stand-up,
he was like, "Hey, man!
What's going on?"
And that's what he sounded like.
And then, he came back
15 years later like the Hulk,
and he's like,
"What's going on, everybody?"
[ Laughter ]
-When you disappear
and come back 15 years later,
do you have a voice
you're gonna use?
-I hope I can make it
another 15 years.
That's the nicest thing
anyone's said.
[ Laughter ]
This [bleep] was so weird.
So they have --
[ Laughter ]
You see -- see that?
So they're, like, crushing it,
right?
-Yeah.
-Clearly, like,
you get what you paid for.
-Yeah.
-And then, so Dave LaChapelle
who was, like,
a pretty famous photographer.
-Yeah.
-So I'm, like, mortified.
And there's ice everywhere,
but I'm still somehow sweating.
[ Laughter ]
And Dave is in the back,
and he's just, like --
I'm obviously not giving him
what he needs,
because I'm not
a [bleep] model.
I'm like -- I'm a dummy.
So all of a sudden, he, like --
And I feel bad because I'm
holding up, like, Emily,
and everybody has [bleep] to do.
So all of a sudden,
Dave stops the thing,
and he goes, "Pete,"
he goes, "you're a fish!"
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "You're a fish.
Be a fish for me, Pete!
You're a fish!
Be a fish!"
And he was like,
"Can you do that for me?
Can you be a fish?"
I was like,
"I guess I can be
a little fishy for you."
[ Laughter ]
-And he was like,
"Yes! That's it!
You're a fish!"
And I was like, "I'm a fish!
I'm a fish!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
-You guys.
-Oh, thank you.
-That's Pete Davidson.
"The Freak Brothers"
is streaming exclusively
on Tubi.
True story. True story.
-Tubi!